[Music]
let's go out to Upstate New York and
talk to the mighty Joseph what's up
Joseph hey how you doing man we're
rocking man thank you so much I'm glad
that you're with us man what's up so
I've uh I'm at this Crossroads in my
life where I can't really figure out how
to uh move on from actions that I've
done or the person I was to the person
I've became long story as short as
possible um I was married and had five
beautiful kids with this woman and uh I
I I wasn't a man yet I was stuck in this
little boy mentality still I never grew
up I didn't learn how to be emotionally
open I got stuck in active addiction and
mental health
untreated and she got the worst part of
me for almost eight years before the
divorce and uh after the divorce uh we
started to move on and I started dating
and when I started dating and and
growing and going to counseling and
getting my relationship right with God I
saw a complete 180 from the man I was
before and uh now every time I get kind
of close to someone and start really
giving them the best part of me after
four years of healing and growth I I
I've started to realize that you know
I'm being a man for for women who is not
the mother of my child you know not
mother of my children and I'm just uh
it's causing me to not be able to fully
commit to people because I feel really
guilty and ashamed that the uh the woman
who birthed five beautiful kids for me
got you know the terrible end of the
deal and I just get in my head about
what would happen if if uh you know she
had received the man that I am today the
one that's able to communicate the one
that's emotionally open the one that has
a relationship with God that she always
wanted me to have with her the
relationship with God you know I'm with
the I'm with a new woman now for six
months and you know it's not by any
means a perfect relationship but we pray
together in the morning we pray together
in the afternoon we do church services
we uh put God first in our relationship
we communicate effectively all things
that you know my wife of eight years was
starving for and begging me for and are
you still struggling with
addiction uh I actually have four years
sober now okay and uh I've been back
right with God for about hold hold on
hold on what what's your repl
M so my replacement was God uh I I
entered God back into my life and uh I
replaced it more with uh dealing with my
problems effectively instead of masking
my problems so I use God and the Bible
and a um a
Christian uh way of life to replace the
things that I didn't like about myself I
used God to kind of replace those things
with better attributes so that I didn't
have to have the feeling of having to
disassociate from the real reality I was
living I think you're still
disassociated and I want you to prove to
me that I'm wrong
okay right now you are punishing
yourself in the present for things that
you did in the
past is that
helping yes it is helping how's that
helping I mean it's not helping but I is
there anything you can do right now is
there anything you can do to yourself
when it comes to fogging or punishing
yourself that's going to get you back
those eight
years no
no and when I say it sounds like you're
still disassociating I think the
discomfort is coming less from this
guilt over how you treated this woman
four years ago and up to 12 years
ago I think you're scared that you're
going to fail
again
definitely and so she this this guilt
this it feels like it's imaginary it
feels like a place to put your hurt onto
without having to look in the mirror and
say I don't trust that guy
yet I agree is that
fair it's 100% fair and
accurate I don't I I I just don't think
you're avoiding commitment because of
the guilt of your of your wife I think
you're avoiding commitment because
you're scared to death
that you're not going to be who you want
to be and so it s like the way you're
talking about all this Christian stuff
good I'm glad that you found faith I'm
glad that you found a set of practices
I'm glad glad you found Common Ground
I'm glad for all that
stuff but you know as well as I do that
can become really
performative yes as a way to sing and
dance and it's a it's a fancy
sophisticated game of look over here
look over here look over
here while you are looking in the mirror
and being and thinking that guy is
disgusting I do I do still beat myself
up a lot I know you do and uh you know I
and that tells me you're not a really
unrealistic standard but that tells me
you're not on the other side of
um it tells me you're not on the other
side of taking a knee and submitting
to I'm out of
control makes a lot of sense there's
Faith there's Faith
performance there's there's there's
religious practice that is a sense of
surrender and then there's Faith
practice as a form of control I'm going
to grab this wheel so tight I can see
the whites in my
Knuckles and that almost always ends in
deconstruction and Ash those that enter
into belief into Faith structures with
their hands
open it's I mean you you can you I mean
if you're watching this on YouTube you
can like watch my shoulders
drop faith and belief as a way of
leaning against God is
against something bigger than yourself
that is different than trying to grasp
hold of and take control of something
infinitely bigger than
you does that does that ring
true yeah definitely that's why just
asking you that's why I just asked like
what what did you trade because it
doesn't sound like you're on the other
side what was your addiction of choice
what was your numbing agent of choice
alcohol alcohol sounds like you put the
bottle away so you're four years without
a
drink yes sir
uh do you work 90 hours a week or do you
have a healthy work balance uh about 70
hours a week out of town uh that was
another thing I I tried to get away from
all these emotions and took my local job
over the road and I'm about 3,000 miles
away from everybody right now there you
go so you did a noble thing you got out
of the bar right very very hard very
hard very Noble I'm super proud of
you and you force gped it you just get
running is that fair definitely
okay and I think you're running from
you that's very fair I always run for me
and uh you know I I don't know whye I
hold myself to this higher expectation
than I hold other people I definitely
don't cut myself any slack or you know I
always feel feel this sense of
inadequacy um in everything I do be at
work or being a father or being in a
relationship or the marriage when I was
in it I I guess I always feel like
whatever I do it's never going to be
enough it's never going to be you know
who are you trying to perform
for I I can never differentiate if I'm
actually selflessly doing it for the
other person or if I'm doing it for like
the status of my own self to make myself
feel
okay it's probably an exhausting thing
trying to parse that out instead of just
going to do the next right
thing because it's probably a mixture of
both is that fair like sometimes I do
the dishes when there when the house is
bananas and my kids are all over the
place and my wife has driven 4 hours in
the car between between us you know a
cross country meet and school and after
school play and violin like and I'll do
the dishes to help my wife out to help
out the ecosystem of the house to help
out everything and it does make me feel
like I'm a good dad and a good
husband all that can be
true if I'm one of those weak husbands
that goes and does the dishes and then I
sit there like a puppy waiting for my
wife to Pat me on the head and tell me
I'm a good boy and if she doesn't I
pout that's lame but I think it's a
mixture of all of it and I think that's
okay do you paralyze yourself with
thinking and thinking and ruminating
over and over and over and over
again always I am the hugest overthinker
okay you know even in my current
relationship it could be something very
minuscule and I will overthink it to the
point that something so minor like a
small little blip and communication
turns into everything is destroyed
everything's WR wrong and I'm into like
survival mode time to fix things when
really it's just like two words that
need to be said was your childhood
chaos very much so yes
okay rumination is a complete and total
waste of your
time the only thing it proves it feels
like you are getting out ahead of things
and it feels like productive helpful
thinking and pre-planning it's not it's
uh it's another drink it's a way to not
feel the current
moment and a way to not make a rational
decision about what comes next it's a
way to avoid all of
that it's a
drug that your body gets addicted
to and my guess is overthinking having
to think about what comes next kept you
safe as a kid is that
fair definitely it was a defense
mechanism of creating an out creating an
escape plan was your mom an alcoholic
no uh just a abusive household with my
mom and my dad very Tous relationship
with no communication just physical
interaction okay so you're literally
getting hit as a kid you have to think
two steps ahead of you're old man so you
don't get his fist in your
face and your body comes up with a
pattern on how to solve and enter into
and out of relationships and it's by
pre-planning and pre-planning and and
observing and watching and and coming up
with another plan another route another
route and another route and you miss
this woman sitting next to you on the
couch saying hey can I just saddle up
next to you cuz I love you you miss all
that exactly right are you in
communication with your five
kids yeah we FaceTime uh two to three
times a day and whenever I'm on home
time from work I actually uh stay in my
oldest son's room he has a futon and I
go I have a very good co-parenting
relationship so I I talk to my kids a
couple times a day when I'm at work and
when I'm home it's all about them for
the week that I'm off of work every
month um your ex-wife y y'all yall still
talk yall act like grown-ups
and oh very much so we're actually
really good friends and we parent better
apart than we did together and and um
we're on such a good level you know we
talk about our current relationships and
we talk about the kids and we're even
there for each other on friendship
levels like if she needs something
that's outside the realm of kids or me
we're always there for each other
um pretty good with that so it sounds
like she's forgiven
you and it sounds like she's made peace
with this as her
life and it sounds like um you've made
peace with this is your life sounds like
the only person that hasn't forgiven
Joseph is
Joseph that makes sense and at some
point you have to understand continuing
to look in the mirror and try to
outperform your dislike for
yourself will be a crash landing every
single
time you can't hate your body into going
into the gym to get in better shape you
can't hate your the way you look into
dieting so that you lose weight you
can't hate yourself into being a better
husband you
can't you have to decide man I really
was struggling and I made some really
bad choices four half half a decade ago
I did and it cost me
everything and the greatest way I can
honor my ex-wife who's now a good friend
of mine who's a good co-parent who's a
good mother to all five of my
kids is to not make the same mistake in
future
relationships and that doesn't start
with singing and dancing that starts
with being a good Steward of the man in
the
mirror I'm going to take care of his
mental and emotional health I'm going to
take care of his relationships I'm going
to take care of his physical
body how much money do you make at your
job what's your annual
income uh roughly 65 to 70,000 I want
you to quit that job and find a $60,000
job in your local community that you
don't have to be on the road so much
stop
running you could probably make 65,000
as a manager of a
McDonald's
and I'm saying that half I'm saying that
half um half with a wink I know it's
easy for me just to lob that I'm just a
podcaster like quit your job
man but I want you to start reimagine
you know when you did you go to AA when
you first got
sober I did I still go to Virtual
meetings for those I still work at
virtual 12ep program you are living your
life at arms
length you go to Virtual AA most most of
your interactions with your kids are
virtual most of your interactions with
your current six-month girlfriend is in
your
head you're going to have to make peace
with being present with people in the
room looking you in the eye and that
probably is pretty uncomfortable huh it
is I have like a overwhelming sense of
anxiety when that happens okay you got
to head into those storms otherwise
you're going to create an entirely
virtual world that feels real but it's
not and your body's going to shut you
down
okay definitely that makes a lot of
sense when you first go to AA what do
they tell you you're going to lose your
friends you're going to lose your
environment you're going to lose the bar
where everybody knows your
name and your life is worth it right
that's what they
say
yes you're there part
two now you have to be stop you have to
find environments where you're not
running all the time you have to find
environments where you you have to be
present and you have to feel that
anxiousness and remind yourself I'm
worthy of being love and I'm worthy of
being
here and when those old stories pop
up I'm not who I once was thank God I've
grown by the way Joseph we all have I
don't know anybody who's super thrilled
with who they were 14 years
ago I don't know anybody I think Jenna
was eight but I don't think any of us
are happy with who we were 14 years go
thank God that we get to grow and learn
new things and thank God for grace and
forgiveness and new
friends and to Circle all the way back
around your religious practices are good
man I'm glad it's much better than going
into a
bar but if you're using Rel religious
practices as a way to grab tight control
of your
life you're going to end up suffocating
yourself belief faith
it's about letting go
into this love that's way way bigger
than you
are God is not something that you can
wrap your hands around and grab hold
of God is somebody you enter into their
presence and take a knee and they pick
you he picks you up and he hugs you so
tight you can hardly breathe and he says
I love you will you love you
too you have to love your enemies
too even when you're your worst
enemy